[Music]
welcome one and all to the h3 podcast
experience we're trying to compete with
Joe Rogan over here
hell yeah my theory is that a podcast
can never compete with an experience
he's got an experience right so I'm
trying to even the playing field a
little bit
you needed sea weed pills or something
yes I need some kind of supplement
experience supplement thank you to hims
a Felix gray an audible for sponsoring
us today and if you haven't already
guessed today I would say our group
arguably the most successful youtuber of
all time Oh Bieber Bieber yeah I can't
there's no argument no number can we say
number two no I because like the idea is
that like if you make stuff outside of
YouTube you're more successful I don't
think that's true I'm saying like there
youtubers make way more money than me
may not agree more people I mean I don't
think it's like you know it's legit and
successful just because you you know in
my mind I feel like it there's some
truth to it if you can escape in a way
it's almost it is an escape because it
really frees you like what you do with
your comedy acts is kind of not
compatible with YouTube you think kind
of I don't know well it's like maybe
maybe not the whole stage and the
lighting and all the coordination and my
appearance for a year yeah well that
that's really why I left are not left I
when I was you moved on I just wanted to
do live stuff I mean even when I was
posting the early videos like I just
wanted to perform on stage I was doing
theater that's what I wanted to do even
I was performing those videos like I'd
be like I really want to go to stage
with these and then I performed them on
stage and if I had posted the video it
wouldn't get that much of a reaction
realize like oh if I didn't post this
stuff and people heard it for the first
time in the room is was it was exciting
so well I didn't introduce you Bo
Burnham okay basically I would say one
of the most beloved called me acts for
the past decade including two of my
favorite what and make happy on Netflix
you see both are Netflix what's on
YouTube yeah what's back on Netflix its
back it's everywhere it's everywhere
folks and he's just written and directed
a new movie that's out today on limited
release right
nationwide in two weeks yeah New York
and LA and then it'll be out somewhere
else
eighth-grade which by the way is getting
rave reviews 98 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes whoa let me hit you with the
sounds actually 99 now whoa they raised
it you're like you know what
98 [ __ ] that yeah yeah 99 ooh can we get
it to 100 can we off that one [ __ ]
loser
no we can sure no yeah can you and the
interns on it here's where he did he's
up two words you know not you're good I
would tell if he had a book hanging it's
all good I went I went like you and with
that I'm free but it does have 100% in
my heart appreciate it I went and I saw
it last night it's very kind of I missed
the screening and I absolutely loved it
you missed the screening I missed the
screening so I went saw it last night
okay okay okay how how are you feeling
about it I mean the movies out it's
getting rave reviews it's getting rave
reviews I'm feeling great I won't say
I'm really grateful to be here I'm a fan
of yours either a fan of the podcast is
true you know and though I haven't been
like posting a lot on YouTube I'm
watching the [ __ ] all the time
really yeah all the time I mean like my
main relationship with the Internet is
as a viewer and as someone just who do
you ask who do you of frequent like who
do you like you're you know you're one
of the few people like it's very popular
that I watch I mean I don't know if it's
like getting to me but like ila I it's
sort of what the movie ended up being
like I love people on the internet then
no one's watching
I love the review review bruh I love to
review bro yeah yeah report of the week
oh yeah he's yeah he's a legend
incredible yeah but I really love like
people on the internet that no one's
watching so I'll often like search
something and then view it by upload
date oh yeah I mean you're a d gritty
yeah so I love deep dives like there's
this dude who's a hoarder who cooks hot
dogs on candles and it's very nauseating
is he have character or is it just the
it's the intrigue of it all does he have
character like it's he very entertaining
or no more bone chilling it's chill yeah
yeah yeah it's like him like can we
should we give him a shout-out I don't
know his name and I don't know it's not
lawyer yeah and it really is like he
takes a tour of his like hoarding house
and he cooks like he calls some sausages
and there's a video of him making
sausages and peaches it's aptly
incredible we could probably pull it out
yeah it's one cooking sausages and it's
really not yeah
Ian try bind us the hotdogs and sausages
or the P calls it sausages and peaches
but it is most certainly hotdogs okay
but no I just like I I don't know but
yeah I watch them from the background
and I want to talk a lot about that but
first I want to ask like what was your
motivation almost for writing this film
because it's a departure it's kind of a
surprise to a lot of your fans of like
oh wow where did this movie come from
it's very specific yeah every - with a
very specific narrative like you had a
purpose so I'm wondering what was what
motivated you kind of to go that route
it was like it's about a girl like a 13
year old girl last week eighth grade and
you know I did stand up for me and found
it already by the way but amazing well I
I it'll be a it'll be a hard living face
conversation I I you know perform Santa
for a long time and I was feeling
anxious and I wanted to sort of talk
about the Internet and my own anxiety in
a way and so I had felt like my anxiety
for a long time was like very specific
to me being a 25 year old comedian with
like an audience and then I would like
do my shows and like young kids would
come up to me and say they felt like me
and they felt like they knew what I was
going through even when I was talking
about was like being on stage in front
of thousands of people I'm like why is
this resonating with you and I just
think the sort of pressures the weird
pressures that are usually only afforded
to like d-list celebrities have now been
democratized and given to everybody so I
was always interested in like who are
the telling a story about someone on the
internet that nobody's watching because
the Internet tends to and the culture at
large tends to only talk about the
people on the internet that are being
mean but the majority people on the
internet and there's a lot more and more
who are just talking to the camera
nobody's watching yeah that's 99 percent
of the videos that are uploaded 99.9 you
know and the kind of the only thing we
talk about is like people that go viral
and as someone that went viral it's
really not that interesting yeah yeah
it's like the actual interesting thing
is just trying to engage with this thing
and trying to be seen and trying to be
heard and to me the people that weren't
being heard were actually engaged
much deeper more honest thing well there
was one of the central themes I think
that I extracted from it was like how
social media or this abundant of all
this going on with YouTube and Twitter
and Instagram is affecting kids because
I think there's a five year difference
between us but when I grew up there was
no like growing up as a kid was hard
enough yeah but then when you have all
this new social media introduced to them
and the way that you portray the girl
how she's glued to these social medias
is very accurate I think like how is
this affecting kids I don't know all the
time is that it I don't quite know
exactly like and truly it was me wanted
to talk about how it felt to me and how
it felt to me was it made me feel
nervous and weird and unsure of myself
and that seems like I you mean social
media yeah yeah just having to sort of
represent yourself having to live your
life and then also live your life on
this other place and then the sense of
like because of that floating behind
yourself through situations I just think
it's like weird and disembody and like a
little disassociative or something but
more than anything it was like I I'm
happy for people to like leave the movie
thinking about that stuff but I don't
want the movie to be like a TED talk or
like gonna be some like finger wagging
[ __ ] because that's what it's so noisy
it wasn't by the way let me just say one
last thing yeah but but like that I
don't know it just feels like the
internet hasn't even in least in popular
media hasn't even been described let
alone figure it out like so so yeah I
just wanted to portray it and portray it
how it feels to her and me a little bit
which is just weird it's just like it's
a lot but if it's not like it's just
shitty it's not like it's like we should
just if we have to our phones in the
ocean we'd be happy it's like it's both
we're super connected we're super lonely
we're super stimulated we're super numb
we're self expressing and objectifying
it's like yeah I wouldn't be here
without the internet you know I mean
like obviously I'm so so grateful for it
but also it's you know there's there may
be a happy medium between like the 60
minutes talking about like yes
narcissistic kids and like come on
creators or whatever the [ __ ] that you
you
tube conversation is where it can't
self-examine at all I feel like well on
my part I'm a grown man more or less and
I've recently pretty much quit using
social media because it's it's honestly
too much for me for me like uh like even
me for a long day ahead like a quota for
myself fry was like I need a post every
day on Twitter once yeah because it in a
way it's like if I don't tweet do I
exist though mmm like am I still in the
minds of these people and I found by the
way that the answer is very much yes you
still do exist if you don't tweet but
like there was just a really unhealthy
interaction I had with it like checking
that first thing in the morning to
assorted to sitting down to pee be on my
phone I was like this is [ __ ] up this
is totally because you don't really get
a lot of time out of that you sit down
at well you mean what does that buy you
like 30 second 30 40 minutes at most
right no that's a condition yeah yeah
we'll get into that but yeah I but that
that is part of what the movies hope
when you get out is that like it isn't
like sit down to pee and you use your
phone and for that so you would just
open Twitter really fast while you were
on the John yeah and if it's cold I'll
piss through the space in the the seat
in the bowl and all over my pants it's
nothing happens does that happen you
still die stepping when I was a kid and
I would have like a morning would and
like cuz your dick points down into the
bowl yeah definitely but you're still
able to pee through the hole yeah soft
yeah I was just kidding so I yeah I was
trying to explore that yeah yeah no no
no I was like totally kidding I just
made up a really specific joke that's
never happened um you've never peed
through the crack when you were a kid
all right let's get off let's get it
let's get off I try to be vulnerable
with you yeah all right but yeah I think
like people people look at me I'm like
am so glad I'm not in eighth grade
anymore I'm so glad I'm not so awkward
on I don't have to deal with social
media and I'm like you're the worst
people on social media are thirty roles
and yeah hit people in their late 20s
like from talking with the kids the kids
have the best chance of being chill on
it cuz they like actually have a little
bit of self-awareness and kind of have
grown up with it it's the 30 year olds
that pretend like they're not
you know addicted to it and be
sooo I just like I can't believe what my
friends look like online I can't believe
there's so many people that I don't mind
in real life and I hate them just hate
them and there's never the opposite
there's never anything like what is it
that they do online that makes you hate
them it's just so transparent right what
everyone's doing things trying to look
like peachy and trying to look PG or
trying to or trying to be ironically
peachy or you know like I mean
humblebrag is the word of right of the
21st century well I heard you say
something that I really liked is
something that's been ringing with me is
like if you ironically hate something
it's not really better than like if you
are Roenick lee if you're self-aware of
doing something that you didn't like
yeah it's not really different you know
everyone like you see that on YouTube a
lot of people being like click baiting
ironically but yeah yeah well you still
know you're still doing that it's like
and I did that when I was 16 17 was like
buy my merch I'm a sellout it's like
that no you're still a [ __ ] yeah he
doesn't being self-aware saves you
nothing you know the most and it's like
the ironic [ __ ] the most ironic [ __ ]
online is like Old Spice commercials and
Geico commercials where they're going on
being like this is a Geico commercial
wink and it's like [ __ ] you yeah there's
like Deadpool it's like a 200 million
dollar movie winking at you and it's
like is that cool yeah I don't know I'm
just saying like this sort of like
surrealist cool crazy Adult Swim like
aesthetic has been totally co-opted by
like Allstate hey on Allstate but you
what I'm saying I feel like it's I don't
know yes it just feels yeah to me let me
ask you how does making a movie compared
to your other creative endeavors that
you've done so far it was good I was
just desperate to work with other people
I was like um you know stand-up you just
look to yourself and I was so tired of
my own head yeah I mean I was just so
tired of my voice in my face so I just
want to work with people again I did
theater like growing up and that's why I
really loved that's not like when I fell
in love with [ __ ] so yeah I was just
about working with people and getting
out of my own head and that was nice
that's awesome because like trying to
explore my own anxiety by being alone on
stage it surprisingly ended up making it
worse you have problems with things I
oh yeah I also have suffered from that
but I'm curious have you found something
that's helped you how long have you been
suffering from anxiety longer in
hindsight than I thought when I was in
high school sophomore year I was in the
in the hospital with stomach problems
thinking uh I just like I did like you
know drank Barry I'm thinking I'm having
all this like of holes in my intestines
and I was just nervous [ __ ] my pants
it's funny I find it interesting that
you weren't aware mmm that it was
anxiety you were feeling well it was so
constant that we I didn't think it could
have been it was every day um which
actually probably should have pointed to
anxiety but but um and then it really
when I was 23 I had my first panic
attack
on stage and then that was like oh she
how did you how did the show continue it
continued I've had like you know you
push through it
yeah I've had about ten on stage and
[ __ ] what happens in that moment you
become like very self-aware tunnel
vision like tunnel vision and then like
you know numb body and then if just a
total like out-of-body feeling and
what's so weird
what's so weird about it is that it's
with it's it's happening within the
structure of a show that is written out
- but - the word you mean sort of like I
can't even like go I'm feeling like I
have to I have to like say so it ends up
like a I'm in Groundhog's Day and I like
or like I have a script they have to
keep - so I have this inner monologue
freaking out and then I'm having to
perform by ground that you're able to
still like perform the script while
having a somewhat out of body experience
yeah I was but it was like it was like
I'd be a little out of breath so I'd be
the the entire show for 20 minutes would
be existing like on like the inhale kind
of um it was definitely was my best work
you know
do you remember for me my anxiety I
think I was diagnosed with like
generalized anxiety disorder and I had
like a very specific moment of like
almost breaking like a breaking point
where it just came out of nowhere did
you have a moment like that it was
actually it I had a panic attack in it
in Providence Rhode Island
which is funny cause like you know I've
taught like people who went
she'll have heard this now don't you
know I don't think my parents were there
and couldn't tell what's happening mmm
Providence Rhode Island it was like a
theater like 3,000 people had a panic
attack was really bad then went to New
York had three shows had a panic attack
in the middle show went to see the
Martian the next day and got very very
angry because it wasn't about anxiety
and I didn't know it felt like so
perfect for my life like how is this
story about a guy alone on Mars locked
and it felt so true to me and then it
was just like about how he's like a good
botanist or something he movies probably
chill I was just in the bad place and
then I had a panic attack on the train
to DC mmm the next day um which was
another show and I had like this was
like the first week of a tour that was
like 45 shows and 50 days and that was
when I was like there's something going
on here yeah like this is bad and I can
never do this again um that that that
was the worst time of my I've had a
pretty fortunate life that was
definitely one of the hardest yeah
stretches of my life and and like how
did you kind of get through it I mean
did you find at the time was it like for
me it was almost unbearable like I
couldn't even live I was completely
debilitated for like six months I would
say try meditation you know I've been
meditating for [ __ ] the problem is
there's just a show every night and
there was like very like surreal comical
things right be like googling how to
deal with stage fright you know before
show in front of 3,000 people and the
answers would be like don't worry like
if you're if you're doing this in front
of your class or at Town Hall like
people don't really write about what
you're saying no no no there's 3,000
people that have paid $40 in or have
waited you know like it is they do care
yeah it like really helped me to find
out that like Barbra Streisand prays
mm-hmm Adele like I get actually really
helped well it's such a weird thing like
how you almost have to be more of a
[ __ ] psycho to not experience anxiety
exactly like it's like being the
president like I don't know how you well
I I've long held that you have to be an
actual sociopath that even want to be
President
yeah so those guys don't feel like yeah
I just feel cold-blooded yeah we got a
good one right now but yeah they're
usually pretty bad yeah he's I I get the
he's not having much self-awareness
self-aware moments right now yeah yeah
no um yeah my Mac I know my body's on
fire
yeah meditation what did you do dude the
thing is like I'm not I I'm like a
somewhat sensitive guy oh yeah but for
some reason I never talk to anyone about
it
like I don't yeah I didn't say our
biggest mistake and that's what [ __ ]
me up for someone and looking back in
hindsight I was like why didn't I why
was I so private about it cuz I thought
I was I thought I was actually having
like a psychotic mic break yeah I was I
thought almost for sure that I was
schizophrenic
mm-hm and I was so crushed by that fact
and I felt like I will crush my parents
by telling them that and I felt just
like I couldn't talk about it at all and
I held on to it just hoping it would go
away but it never did for me I don't
know if you felt this like my worry was
if I say it it's real yeah do you mean
like if I admit that I'm going through
there it's it's I've spoken it and now
I'll never stop think about it and it is
for anyone worried about this it is the
exact opposite it's like speaking it is
the salvation so that's what helped me
is when I finally talked to them about
it because you it's just like it's like
stand-up it's just you and your head
talking to yourself and it makes
everything so much worse because when
you talk to somebody about it first of
all it's really a very very literal
getting it out but then people can talk
to me like looking you're not [ __ ]
you're not schizophrenic you're not
dying
it's just anxiety like the things that I
hoped for myself but wouldn't believe
people were confirming for me that was
the beginning of of healing but I think
the thing that really changed for me was
having a sick like a significant other
and my wife right someone that really
like I felt comfortable talking about it
and being myself and knowing that
because a lot of the anxiety that I had
was very much like social in a lot of
ways yet you know yeah right yeah of
course so a lot of that was alleviated
when you find someone that like you
think doesn't care
yeah and you're alone in it together or
whatever that thing you can hate the
world army of two or something yeah
yeah could everyone get said yeah that's
beautiful yeah I never took medicine
though but frankly I wish I did yeah I
think I would have helped a lot I almost
took beta blockers for performance when
I felt like I was gonna beta blockers
we've talked about that here I don't
know what the [ __ ] beta blockers I don't
know anything and it sounds like it's
like a 90s board game or something yeah
but I don't really feel like doing it
but yeah man it's like the sort of my
thing was like enough I'm being like
truly honest with myself it's like the
two sides of the same coin that like I
by speaking it out loud and seeing that
other people were going through it and
and that it wasn't unique to my
experience of being because I just
thought like oh it's this is happening
to me because I'm living an insane life
in a very specific circumstance you know
mm-hmm when I spoke it I realized like
it's the two thing it was the thing I
was most terrified of and the thing that
actually saved me which is like I'm not
unique and I'm not alone
you know I think I was maybe deep down
wanting it to be singular because you
know I've just you know I want to have a
very singular experience and you know
when I'm going through you can
understand I think that that sort of
mindset is common to anxious people an
idea of it is so visse sort of describe
it like having anxiety feels like like
I'm riding a bull like my bull is inert
my nervous system and I just have to
hold on to it and then like being in the
world feels like everyone else is an
equestrian
you mean just like perfectly in sync
with their own system and it just it
just isn't true oh so many silent
battles of it and absolutely for some
and it's so weird like what I I hadn't I
thought I saw a little bit of my special
that I hadn't seen you know in make
happy the last one in two years and I
saw it and I couldn't
I would not believe that person was
nervous yeah yeah I believe I would
think like oh he's talking about anxiety
to just you know if he thinks it's like
in and and and but like he's not nervous
and I was I frankly didn't know that it
was such a battle for you after the
first show I sobbed sobbed backstage
because because like I mean I I slept
two hours the night before I was shaking
like
yeah uh yeah it was it was rough it was
um it's incredible they're like even
through that you can still do [ __ ] cuz
like thinking back on myself I wasn't
famous at the time when I was having my
worst anxiety I mean I still suffer from
it a lot but like back in the day I was
so like even just talking to someone was
almost like a a bat like a real battle
for me yeah going on a date was like the
[ __ ] like very much like what the
movie yeah it's crabs is like these
mundane ordinary things can sometimes be
the bravest thing you can do exactly and
that's what the movie was trying to do
is like portray it very much and it were
lost for a 30 I appreciate it it's like
13 year old life for a 13 year old or
someone with social anxiety every tiny
moments feel like life and death and it
is it's so important to overcome it and
just say you know what I still have to
do this and I feel like that is really
what makes you overcome it yes and and
like I just think movies tend to over us
push situations into drama and
confrontation then that needs to justify
oh yeah I think people are so [ __ ]
non-confrontational in real life so
non-confrontational like have you ever
like just raised your voice at a guy in
like the grocery store line and then
your heart is pounding for 40 minutes
afterwards like yeah like have you seen
them are you're like holy [ __ ] you know
III just think life is very the drama of
our lives literally plays out very small
but subjectively and personally it's
very very big so the movie was just
trying to be like can we show those tiny
tiny moments in our ego successfully
like the scene where she's going to the
pool party was just like like I felt
that so much you know what I mean and I
think everybody watch you will feel it
so much so definitely I love that so
much capturing yeah yeah yeah cool
parties are just not chill and we were
trying to also like really try to look
at kids not nostalgically not like a
memory but to try to see them like yeah
yeah aliens like what if we just forgot
what these things meant to us in
hindsight but just looked at it fresh
and it's like yeah
a pool party's like okay it's like okay
so forget everything you know Barney
forget that it's like a cultural
standard and realize that it's like okay
it's like
bunch of kids whose bodies are exploding
half-dressed a hole in the ground with
waters like wow how is this part of our
lives like yeah how is this any passage
like rite of passage for kids yeah it
finally like you just touched on it
doesn't get better as an adult
godo you imagine going I cannot imagine
like taking off my shirt yeah the worst
ever yeah yeah I'm still like I wouldn't
do that now I would just not do it
would you but you go in with a shirt on
did you do that and then you were kid I
was shirt on in the pool what yeah I'll
tell you why I was shirt on I had a
giant mole on my back healthy and
removed Congrats my mom did it by moms
we know it was can't she thought it was
cancerous cuz it was like this [ __ ]
big but that's why I was shirt on now I
keep the shirt on because I'm fat hold
up wait your mother your mother removed
him all off your back she okay
maybe I described that weirdly she opted
for it to be removed oh my literally
come with me think about where you think
I went and that's not what happened at
all yeah okay chill yeah but we got that
covered
okay that's good that's great yeah I
would the sad [ __ ] is I would always
work wear my t-shirt in the pool but I
would like pretend like you mean I like
fall into the pool be like oh [ __ ] my
shirt oh yeah that's
oh it's rough right you know everyone
even as a kid everyone's like come on
dude yeah you really really like you
forget how self-aware you are at that
age like at that age you're in on the
joke of yourself like you're making fun
of each other for your voice is cracking
and [ __ ] like you know what's going on
yeah yeah yeah it's brutal shirt on man
I've seen a fully clad I mean shoes and
everything yeah and that before oh
that's pretty beat yeah
damn so would you shirt on these that
you weren't shirt on if you went to a
pool
I don't pool yeah boy other yeah yeah
I'm an endorsement most thank you yeah
do you have it what a you would you camp
do you do any outdoor activities would
you play video game what do you have I
don't know what do you outside people
camp yeah people there's [ __ ] out
there Oprah know there's people out
there that
do stuff and I'm and I'm genuinely
jealous I say when I meet somebody I'm
like you're the kind of guy that does
stuff aren't you I know that you know a
part of me that's like yeah if I just
like ate the right stuff and went hiking
and things I'd be happy but can you
imagine going hiking
no can I imagine everyone and I've never
went never
I just everyone hikes here I've never
been they seem so happy they're out
there they don't mind instead of lying
about it no no way Dan are you I mean I
know that like like Dan and Ian are very
much people that do stuff and I go who
are you well you meet these people
they're like that was Dan sorry Dan do
you go hiking no I mean when when a
girlfriend a few years ago she would
force me to all the time but that's that
doesn't really count he didn't like it
though yeah was that the main problem in
the relationship yeah that she wanted to
hike she dumped her yeah all right
yeah I like those people are you jealous
people that do stuff cuz I know they're
always planning stuff they're going to
like art exhibits yeah they're all sides
again thrilled when they find a bag of
like dried cranberries like I don't want
to live that life find a bag address you
me they're all like oh you mean I don't
want to eat like Eggo waffles and drink
redbull I'm saying what are you what's
your main hobby you probably work a lot
no no I have a true true
lazy streak like truly I like will sit
around for a long long time and then
like have a burst of doing something and
then what do you do when you're at home
a Holmes men home spin I got dogs got
double friend okay I kiss my dogs walk
my girlfriend kiss I like a 1930s joke I
I watched a lot of my know I watch a lot
of stuff this is my problem I'm home all
day and I don't know what I do yeah I
don't know I don't know if that's what
you're getting at I'll spin I'll be at
home all [ __ ] day and at the end of
the day I'll be like I did I don't even
I didn't even like turn on a show and
watch a show like at least I would be
able to say I did that
but I don't know what I do
watch like videos are like 10 year-olds
doing like Yankee Candle hauls what like
10 year olds like they they there's a
lot of Yankee it's like 10 year old kids
with like three Android subscribe errs
then like go to Yankee Candle and bring
a bunch of candles home and their lower
hall a candy yeah yeah yeah no no I got
a cop like this it's pepper man and it's
not like it smells like peppermint it's
the greatest [ __ ] ever Wow
okay I can tell you you're very you're
home you're home Schmidt yeah oh yeah
yeah I don't um you play video games
yeah I play if I got psvr
I'm very excited about that if there was
a people I want to make my movie for VR
if there was anything else my movie
could be I wish could be VR what does
that mean you're just one of the kids
kind of yeah yeah know what I'm saying
that VR actually like inspired the movie
a little bit visually like wanting to
feel like you're in this thing kind of
looking around mmm and like when people
start making like really cool short
films and stuff on that there's been a
few it's gonna be it's incredible it's
like an it's a new medium not in the way
like television and movies or different
mediums it's it's a different medium in
the way like movies and books are good
for me so I'm very excited bout that but
I got switch and playing Mario Tennis
aces sweet I love the switch yeah I just
do handheld yeah I don't [ __ ] with the
yeah well do you play it what do you
play on the TV or no see I I do all that
yeah I like the TV yeah
we're different but I heard it's you
editor I heard it
you really have to split hairs define
different it's like I'm a handheld
switch man you're a but it's better
graphics on the TV yeah yeah there's a
TV for [ __ ] sake that's right
is it t that checks out alright let's go
to a quick break we will be right back
when we get back I want to ask you all
about like kind of I've got a question
is the viral video dead you know
let's ask that when we come back thank
you too for hemes for sponsoring this
episode of the h3 podcast did you guys
know that 66% of men start losing their
hair by age 35 now I started using for
hims about I'd say two days ago and I
don't want to brag or anything but not
only is my hair looking more luscious
and thicker than
ever but I'm also feeling particularly
powerful today guys it's much easier to
keep the hair you have than to replace
the hair you've lost have you noticed
that hairline receding do you want to do
something about it well guess what
baldness is an option okay and you don't
have to be that guy any longer the
solution for hims calm a one-stop shop
for hair loss skin care sexual wellness
for Men Ian for example started taking
for hims how long ago was it in about 24
hours ago 24 hours I mean Wow
results may vary I want to emphasize on
that but as worked out really well for
in yeah fix my hairline change my rate
thank you so much and I'm glad we could
help you out there's a well-known
generic equivalent to name-brand
prescriptions to help you keep your hair
this is not snake oil pills or gas
station counter supplements
this is prescriptions backed by science
there's no waiting room no awkward
doctor visits you're gonna save hours by
going to for hims dot-com it's so easy
dan what is your opinion of for hims
it's done a lot of good for me I'm you
as you as you could see we are all
feeling great and our hair is I don't
want to say Super Saiyan but I mean
we're feeling really good about it let's
just put it that way the products get
shipped directly to your door after you
answer a few quick questions a doctor
reviews it and prescribes you the
medicine so here's what you need to do
or - right flipping out my listeners get
a try out month for four hams for just
$5 today right now while supplies last
see the website for full details this
would cost hundreds of fricking doll
hairs if you went to a doctor or
pharmacy so go to for hanscom's slash h3
that's fo r hims comm slash h3 for hims
Cobb slash h3 results may vary in this
case but it's gonna help you a lot
thank you to felix gray guys if you're
like me you spend a lot of time on the
computer a lot way too much and here's
what you need to know
those blue lights coming off there are
gonna fu the Frick up that's why I
recommend Felix gray glasses check this
out these glasses block out the blue
light to prevent digital eye strain
which can give you a headache dry eye
and really just a whole magnitude of
issues that are just frankly gonna ruin
your whole life yeah it's tough out
there folks and look you don't have to
look like a nerd if you're trying to use
the computer all day you can look
stylish and slick and maybe somebody
will actually look at your dick I don't
know about touch but look yes the rest
is up to you to secure a lot of us spend
hours and hours of front of the computer
staring at screens and it gets
exhausting even if you've never heard of
digital eye strain chances are you've
experienced it when I'm on the computer
all day I get headaches it sucks because
I don't leave the computer I never stop
I just sit there with a headache until I
got these glasses beautifully designed
by Felix gray feel this great lenses are
specifically designed to filter blue
light and eliminate glare from the
screen which are the two main culprits
behind digital eye strain they have blue
light filtering technology embedded into
the lenses so you're they're effectively
without the tell-tale yellow tint or
color distortion of other blue light
filtering glasses
Felix gray frames are handcrafted from
premium Italian acetate the same
material used by the biggest designer
brands in the world and they're super
stylish this is the Turing style
I love it because it makes me look
studious and handsome and sweet assuming
guy that's secretly just a nerd that
wants to spend 15 hours a day on the
computer but they don't know that
because these look cool no prescription
is necessary their glasses are available
and non-prescription reader and they've
just launched prescription lenses so
everyone can benefit from wearing a pair
of Felix greys all orders are shipped
free and free returns so you've got
nothing to lose folks give it a shot go
to felix great glasses dot-com /h their
tribe pair of felix grey glasses today
that's Felix gray glasses comm /h three
Felix gray glasses comm /h three link is
in the
chin guys you got nothing to lose give
it a shot if you have problems at the
computer with eyestrain try them on see
if it doesn't change your life forever
audible you know it you love it
guess what they've got a special offer
that's gonna hook you in check this out
audible has an offer that ends July 31st
of this year Amazon Prime members can
get audible for five dollars a month for
the first three months that's like
getting three months for the price of
one and after those three months it's
just 15 dollars a month now you know I
love audible it's basically changed the
game for me because I can listen to a
book it's like doubling your
productivity if you want to listen to a
novel or I get yeah you know a self-help
book or you want to learn whatever
you're doing you're exercising you're
playing video games there's nothing
better than accompanying those
activities with audible at the same time
folks audible has the largest selection
of audiobooks on the planet guess what's
on audible now Harry Potter the frickin
books are all on audible now the whole
series I started listening in the first
book it's enchanting it's a blast
I've personally read all those books
they're one of my favorite series guys
if you haven't gotten into the Harry
Potter series now is a great time to try
audible and listen to those right flip
in now gosh darn it
audible members get a credit every month
good for any audiobook you guard 'less
of price and unused credit credits roll
over to the next month if you didn't
like the audiobook you can exchange it
for another one no questions asked folks
it doesn't get better I've got the
soundboard here I'm gonna use it your
books are yours to keep with audible you
can go back and re-listen anytime even
if you cancel your membership so good
audible.com slash h3 podcast or text h3
podcast one-word to five hundred five
hundred to get started and remember
Amazon Prime members can get audible for
five dollars a month for the first three
months that's like getting three months
the price of one come on and after that
is $15 a month so once again guys this
offer ends July 31st go to audible.com
slash h3 podcast one word go listen to
Harry Potter I'm telling you now is the
time to get your wand out and start
doing some abracadabra or what is that
one at all right you guys are gonna love
it
hello and welcome back it's ya boy bo
here let me ask you this you had your
big brains this is a big thing for you
right elbows on the table yeah I don't
know I have Sting's I'm not very soft I
do this a lot I know this we just talk
about anxiety and that that's horrible
well you know I used to say fascinating
it's a good word but I lean on it a
little bit
yeah and I got memed into the [ __ ]
ground that's incredible and I watched
like late-night shows and I watch people
and they say I listened to a lot of
podcasts they say fascinating a lot
faster you please you can even have its
own destiny you can tell whatever throws
of listen you like I can't get it away
from it you can tell what bros have been
listening to Jordan Peterson by how all
of a sudden they start saying
presupposition presupposition I'm like
that's cool bruh I know where you got
yeah yeah yeah oh my god dan just a man
what come on this is not fascinating at
all no no yeah I thought we the
presupposition was that you weren't
gonna come in here this was presupposed
so let me ask you you came up cut I'm
coming up I want the world to know I got
a lens show
yeah you got a ledge show this is so you
came up but you you went viral right
hell yeah I feel like back then going
viral it was that hashtag hashtag virus
like viral I became an internet
sensation Walker my love and please keep
using it and it was true back then there
was such thing as I felt like it was
real viral videos and viral videos real
Meyer yes
meant like from nothing yes from like
the depths of yes [ __ ] of YouTube
important cannot go viral No
you plug James I'm saying love to jail
you can't go that's not virality a virus
yeah it's like a dude [ __ ] a monkey he
got a and from the depths of out of
nowhere AIDS was born exactly viral but
it's like oh I got a cold it's like well
the colds been around that's not you
know what that's a weird analogy it's a
weird analogy but maybe you know what I
mean it's more like you have eight
million subscribers most of your
subscribers saw your [ __ ] thing it
didn't go viral yeah you just yeah
exactly it's like I don't like my
question is do viral video still exist
because I don't see that happening
anymore they do they do i I don't think
like yeah I don't think I would have
worked now I don't think I would have
been discovered it's a bummer I don't
like why is that what do you think cuz
YouTube turned into a [ __ ] studio and
and the network and you go to the
trending page and it's [ __ ] late
night late night clips movie trailers in
music videos it's like [ __ ] like you
mean like when we start I was like this
is gonna be the people's medium that was
like cool and never and now it's just
like I don't know why they do I really I
don't understand why they do that I
don't either it's like - just don't put
that [ __ ] there they don't need the
[ __ ] views and the best they do is
like support their creators but are they
supporting like no the the little
creators they the ones with a bunch of
subscribers don't need help and III
don't know the specifics are know people
are getting [ __ ] over specifically but
it's like oh it's kind of like the class
of 2006 - 11 rows or whatever and like
or you know I think it's hard to become
anything now I think like the
established it's really hard to break
through them yeah and the only people
that I see breaking through now are
basically people who are producing just
really just really the worst stuff
that's very easily consumable that's
very clickable
I think the thumbnail in the title are
so important now it looks why is that
it's really that's like people start
there and then work back it's funny yeah
cuz I remember I all my videos were
posted like lower case just the title of
the song you mean I really like
even me later and clips had to do big
capital bo burnham HD whatever the [ __ ]
but that's not but like bill wursts bill
works the guy that did the history is
the one excuse no but i think there are
some others i i'm sure there are and and
again it's not it's not that I wouldn't
say it's not the kids the specific
people posting themselves that aren't a
value it's just I think the value system
or whatever that's like that you're
taught to you know and I don't think it
encourages people to be creative like it
used to right or got out of the way it's
like I don't know it's crazy well alone
I didn't think it was all gonna turn
into vlogging yeah give me and like
that's cool if you vlog but like even
musicians like on YouTube they're like
little indie musicians start their music
video with like hey guys this is my
music video I hope you check it out I'm
gonna custom I'm like whoa well I think
the problem is that YouTube's algorithm
favors lots like daily or even more than
daily uploads of basically to succeed on
YouTube in this environment you have to
post like every day in fan engagement
yeah that is kind of like crazy turn
that's just like what's on top right now
because it's what YouTube is selected
probably inadvertently to dominate right
and it's not that it's not that there
shouldn't be that I mean there are
people yourself included who are very
good at commentary who should be posting
a lot but that should be one part of an
ecosystem I'm saying in theory this
thing is just a blank medium right where
anything can post for anything can I was
just I just remember in 2006 being like
oh man I wonder what YouTube's gonna be
like in ten years it's gonna be like all
the oscar-winning shorts or I mean who
doesn't matter the oh yeah yeah there's
like Oscars right I'm just saying it's
gonna be people are gonna be uploading
you know like what when I made my
special I made this big thing of like
I'm gonna post it for free on YouTube
you know and then give it to Netflix but
I took way less of a pay so I could post
for free on YouTube I posted for free on
YouTube but I realized like the
environment had changed so much there's
like a no one even thought I was posting
it they just thought it was like a rip
from Netflix and I was like
man this place doesn't even exist for
that anymore really that's true and then
you see [ __ ] I mean I don't know so
I'm sure there's some really good stuff
I want to be [ __ ] on people I'm like
these are things I struggle with these
are pressures I feel um but it's like I
don't know around town I see billboards
for YouTube brand I'm like it looks like
a Disney Channel like isn't this place
the Wild West isn't this like totally
free why are we imposing like wire and
it feels like creators themselves are
inviting like the archaic standards of
Hollywood to themselves it's like you
can be so much freer than this
I would think why why are you making
Jeremy and I think that well if you look
at someone like filthy Frank I don't
know if you that know who that knows no
he was someone who kind of embodied what
you're talking about where he was very
much his own man he very much did his
own thing didn't conform to any anything
he was just totally [ __ ] nuts and
everybody loved it but the problem was
that he was always being demonetized
YouTube was always [ __ ] with his
videos in a way that didn't really make
it sustainable
I guess look at you nice who like uses
you nice drink glue he was old uh what
did he say to you nice is he's a legend
legend he called ela an Israeli [ __ ]
once and they wanted to kill her or
something but I was like she oh nice we
still got all my help me my girl we
always said thank ya but it just like
yes but Jun Isis he's not killing it
anymore
well he's killing well he's never he's
yeah he's killed but not it but like I'm
just saying it should be weird or right
that's all I just I just mean it should
be like but I'm glad he said Bill works
because that does kind of our works and
and you know what I know that there's
like hundreds of them thousands that
just the system isn't in place to I'm
saying like what I'm saying really is
not going after the people making stuff
yeah and even the people making stuff
could would be so much better if the if
the medium itself was encouraging actual
creative expression I wish they had a
department or some kind of dedication to
doing that but as far as I'm aware
they're just they don't why are bunch of
NBC executives yeah look the people that
work at YouTube are like a bunch of
[ __ ] dusty
I should be saying this [ __ ] but
whatever oh whatever I'm friends with
them they know they know we all hate
them all right they live with that yeah
it's like yeah when you walk into
YouTube headquarters you're like is this
the M&M store where the [ __ ] am I mean
it's like I don't know the Internet to
me is like dirty and weird and crazy and
like so human and if you did just
scratch past the surface you fall that's
not part of the problem this happening
is that like with net neutrality and all
all this stuff going on is that people
don't want the Internet to be that dirty
crusty place anymore they want it to be
you know buttoned up and they want it to
be predictable and they want it to be
not just another thing yeah I mean
that's that's where the movement is
going yeah it's hard because I think I'm
on both sides a little bit because I
also look at the internet and don't go
like the only problem with the internet
isn't that it needs to be free or you
know I mean there's I mean there's also
crazy you know I don't know if any of us
should be able to watch like people blow
their heads off you know I mean and
stuff like I don't know if but but or
worse yeah blow they're much much worse
than that
oh yeah yeah yeah I got I got you it she
was into snakes
yes yeah it's well what do you think of
when you came up on YouTube there wasn't
such a notion as as internet celebrity
or YouTube so no and there wasn't a
standard there wasn't like a thing you
should be there wasn't like a there
wasn't a format mm-hmm so it was just
like people just doing random [ __ ]
unpolished random [ __ ]
which is cool you know as opposed to
like if you want to you know I don't
know so what do you what do you thought
the old dude but no but I am yeah but I
am I am across the old duda that you
mean I was in 2006 driving this thing
started and yeah and but it's because I
care about it so much
yeah and I want you know young people
that are taking risks and making
interesting things to like have a and
it's I say this because I care about it
because like every other medium has no
[ __ ] chance like of being cool really
like yeah this is like the first like
real medium were like everyone can
actually access it
and like the virus even the idea of
viral is ism is a is a problem because
it because it immediately puts the idea
that the only things worthy are the ones
that are that are being seen like a
million times you find really cool
channels with like 3000 views or it's
some like person giving advice or some
or a person teaching piano well
originally that's what YouTube was all
about was just a dude who wanted to make
[ __ ] and share it with like their
friends I mean that's why people made
videos and in the early days before you
got paid for it mm-hmm but now it's like
I think 95 percent of kids if you ask
how much their dream job is to be a
youtuber yeah I find that pretty strange
huh
when I was a kid people wanted to be
astronauts well youtubers weird because
it feels like it's like movie no I guess
they would just be like moving but
youtuber it's weird that when you say
youtuber that should have no meaning
right that should actually be like
something this amount yeah exactly
should be writer so it's like oh what do
you want to write but when you say
youtuber it's like oh that means like
how my image hey like this for that you
know that that's yeah very true that but
I don't think that's true but I don't
think it actually is true it just I
think got neighbors that are getting
attention yeah yeah that is what they
mean yeah I know what you mean I love
you too my love so much of what it was
yeah what it is kids are like I get I
watch it I like it so I'm saying if kids
are happy and everyone's happy doing
this shouldn't people happy watching it
that's like totally cool and and I need
to emphasize that like the real thing
I'm pissed about is not that that that
popular YouTube creators are taking the
space from these kids the real thing are
the movie studios the movie trailers The
Tonight Show clips that like that is the
most infuriating thing when you see like
um I thought that Shane Dawson Tanic on
thing was awesome yeah that was so cool
that that was incredible yeah and like
what an incredible thing to do like form
breaking it came up and it was so good
like that was blown away and it was it
was part and because of like Shane
personal relationship with his odd it
was that much more meaningful so it's
like a great like version of that like a
Louis Theroux weird version so that was
awesome yeah so I know people are doing
that I just want to be like you know
like I don't know like Kevin Hart doing
like Vanity Fair's and you know most
viral questions whatever you mean and
stuff and all that no hate to any
specific people I'm just saying like no
I know exactly if it were I can't
believe it like they do it these people
sit in a room and they go like how can
we make something viral and they make it
and it goes viral because they called it
viral in their headline well I like he
said I don't think that means anything
anymore like viral it was just back in
the day it was like there's a viral
video yodel boy and it was it was a
double rainbow you know what I mean like
that's a viral video it's a guy [ __ ]
tripping balls over a cup and I mean
that's yeah you know I don't think it's
trippin balls I think he's just deeply
bad that guy was attributing ball what
is that right I personally think and I
this is a time time old boom goes the
dynamite boom the best of all time what
are the best of all yeah and like it's
similar with the movie which is like
cringe means a lot to me
you mean like and there's something like
I love like and like are cringe and that
all that stuff is it gets a little dark
I know I think we're the cringe
communities very sometimes can be very
mean yes but I like all the videos but I
breathe air like deeply beautiful to me
they're deeply vulnerable and wonderful
and meaningful tryst and I'm saying like
some people watch the the weird hot dog
video the guy blending the things and
wanna like tell him to kill himself
whatever but I think it's like just so
beautiful that we have access to
people's most more than my moments I
feel for them and I think cringing is a
form of empathy and you know certainly
it is you're you're embarrassed for them
yeah so like and it's an its vulnerable
and I get boom goes the dynamite think
that's that is me on stage if I just
wasn't as good or what or not you know
if I was that that is what it was
happening for me is that I could just
power through it he's like having a
panic attack
yeah and Reggie Miller is looking good
Reggie Miller is the best [ __ ] ever
yeah later he gets the rebound passes it
to the man well speaking of viral videos
I mean you mentioned
you mentioned the hotdogs peach and Ian
found it now first of all this video
this is a reupload because i guess he
erased it it was too too wild for this
world yeah but this has 200,000 views so
we are really this guy it kind of has a
little bit of a fan base yeah well so
anyone can make it yeah see this is this
is it's love money after the
conversation we had it's gonna act like
I want more of this which is just like
sad like name rest man we need more of
this yeah let's see do you know where
this guy is the he's in his kitchen or I
mean like if I dad I wonder what was the
impulse this guy had to be like I want
to share this but that's true what is no
but that's beautiful right Jimmy so this
guy lives is I mean but he's not even
taking inventory of what's in his house
but he's making the video as the as if
this is normal and as if people want to
learn how to make hotdogs and peaches I
mean it really is in a bathroom no but
this is truly beautiful and so deeply
sad and funny and tragic so we're
learning about its life seeing all these
oh so the sausages are just actual
[ __ ] hot dogs I love that he calls it
sausage he's feeling a little bourgeois
today but he's reaching for something
but he wants to teach us he he wants to
share it's beautiful and it's beautiful
he's like you know but basically what it
implies is that it took me a lot to be
able to learn I've learned the skills
yes of cooking these hot dogs yeah and I
think there's a sausage sorry I don't
mean to downplay the corm anus of it any
of these blending pieces okay but
basically I found this secret this
wonderful look at him cooking it I'm
sorry oh I miss I am does that I don't
know if that
just a little zap I'm saying it is
invent I mean it's different he's like I
found this new way to do this you guys
it's but it's like I don't I can't
explain it this means a lot to me this
is beautiful and why have I not seen
this this is really something
why have I seen this that's the real
question you this is this sounds like
it's right up your max of salsa I mean
but I'm saying this is a glimpse into a
life we never would have without this
right pray to God you never have a
glimpse into this life right but but but
not that not that we're just seeing it
we're seeing it through his POV yes and
like with his perspective with his wants
it's incredible it's to me it's so
cinematic and incredibly it's like some
crazy beautiful like Harmony Korine like
here let me crank the volume actually
want to watch this it's eight minutes so
it's a lot it's a lot giving his cat is
he gonna throw those dogs in the blender
with the peaches god it's healthy in a
way he's like listening a little protein
a little fiber you have to a balanced
meal okay let's skip forward to that
yeah the [ __ ] he had what action get
one point washes the thing in the sink
but the dog he watches the dog you got
it when you gotta rinse the dogs folks
look at the trash in the ground and look
at he just really tossed that in there
in a way that quite never got a little
Emeril going on a little yeah oh why is
it it why is there Weiser toilet there I
don't understand the toilet his his
accent is also like implacable really
unplaceable so let's cut to the the big
moment if you're worried this isn't
exciting for the audience trust me it is
it's just sad scene there he's lit these
look look look look whoa now because I
started the [ __ ] he started the wrong
his place was just about to break down
yeah cuz he started the wrong because he
was overreaching he probably hasn't done
this before oh you think this is a new
recipe but he's nobody's
act like an actor he's a Tostitos man
I've noticed oh yeah its brand loyal
just saying but wouldn't the world be a
better place if we watch this with love
am i insane mmm
no you're not it's saying I mean I think
people do but also people are too you
have to have a certain level of maturity
to be like I love this guy and not be
like this guy's a [ __ ] loser yeah I
mean I think most people probably over
the age of 20 are like I said having
sympathy for repulsed in just whatever
yeah
listen don't worry well let's go let's
get to the fireworks yeah let's get some
yeah let's get some I'm trying
which is that towards the end look at Oh
oh my god he's nervous he's like oh you
see it double the cups up if you notice
so he's by you
hip-hop artist all right well yeah he
doubled up I think he just cherishes the
content so much no think there's a drop
so imma correct me if I'm wrong he
didn't blend the dogs he sliced them
little bites and not well he did he
blend it I'll put it into the already
blended peaches yeah yeah okay I'm just
trying to get the recipe straight so for
[Laughter]
clean ups a breeze you just leave
everything there for 10 years
seriously hold on I'm suspicious of this
can I say that okay okay but but in what
way
I think it's might be an art piece oh
it's an art piece but I regardless I
don't think this guy's real I think he
might be an actor no no you know what
I'm saying way too specific oh good way
to spin he hates it he pours it out and
yet still uploads it see now you can oh
now you're getting that no but it
they're all they're all like that it's a
cold I can show you the video even
nine-year-old that is a claw machine in
his house because his mother like like
putting like reverse mortgage on her
house to buy him a claw machine that
also looks like an art piece
I believe this that they're like a and
pull that up that's really gonna be hard
to find that was like super but like the
it's like claw machine boy I guess this
is just that this I mean I'm not saying
that it's for sure fake but I'm so
skeptical the thing is this predates
kind of the era I'm so skeptical of
everything I see on the Internet to the
point where I'm like I don't know that
this is real of course no there's
there's what they do bring all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] into there why not it's
just why is there a toilet in the bowl
why is there a toilet in the room he
goes to the bathroom
why is he cooks in the bathroom yeah
does he live in the bathroom ok you
gotta just take the whole thing as a
package you can't pick and choose but
that's I just I'm just saying I have
I've seen red flash he's okay so he's
cooking he's frying hot dogs and peaches
and you're confused that he's going to
the bathroom to get the water
no but it's also perfect it wouldn't be
that hard to throw some Tostitos in a
back and bathroom okay either way I
listen I don't I don't want to take I
think it's real you don't have to know I
like of all the conspiracies I've had to
walk people through you know I'm not
much happier to do this than like the
moon the moon is real I think the moon's
real as far as I could and just think
the moon's real you have a moon down Oh
deeply deep he would he would drawed but
my friend drawed Carmichael who I did a
special Frasier he's very um well what's
his theory about the moon not that it's
not real or does he actually think it's
like a hologram
oh no no though going to the moon never
happened yeah no no they're going to the
moon didn't how do you still believe
that in this day and age that really
blows my mind he makes a good case
really you might try to convince me he
would do a good job I I don't believe it
but but um the moon is fake ladies and
gentlemen you heard it look at the moon
it doesn't exist at all all right well I
I do want to see how this ends if I can
be frank deal I mean it looks very real
everything
if it's fake it's the greatest
production designer of all time brutally
like it's beautifully put together
that's true this guy would be going
places right now
oh he would be like like it's a just
it's just like incredibly setup the flat
the two flashlights are you kidding me
that's incredible detail yeah oh he's no
he's not American you know that right he
sounds like Scandinavian or something
speaking English where'd you hear that
he said I hadn't caught that before
abandoned for a couple days yeah go back
let's put the pieces together this might
be oh what that's weird
what is his house like where is if this
is where he goes to cook
why does and why would a guy like this
have like a another he's got two houses
[Laughter]
with like a bun like 15 just [ __ ] holes
this is real by the way
that but that detail like who you'd met
you could never you guys know I write it
and could never write it yeah stranger
than fiction as they say just [ __ ] with
you this is us right now okay you want
click it let's see is this weird Wow
this is us live right now I hate it you
know you have to will you have to wait
till we open us live okay here let me
mute it so at least that it no no you
have to go but then it's like it's so
bad cuz they hear us through the laptop
and it was just prepare it I've made
that mistake before okay this is so
weird that like yeah this is too meta
this is a this is a panic attack right
now bass yeah this is what it feels like
yeah this is I'm having a panic attack
right now oh that's good did wait can we
get more meta with it well I just we
just cut to the wide so in a moment it's
gonna okay games with dreams within
dreams have you seen lights camera
Jackson's
interstellar review best reviews of all
time by the way I just want to say okay
like that um eighth grade the reviews
keep going up during the break there
like Rotten Tomatoes up it's at a ninety
nine point nine points ya know it's at
ninety nine point nine and it's like if
you can get all like B minuses and still
have a hundred percent well that's fine
I mean it's still a good measurement
it's like yes or no you don't mean yeah
yes and it's an emphatic we all loved
this peaches are sausages and we got all
peaches baby it's all peaches here by
all seasons a day um how do we where do
we go from there
um I got some other stuff we could talk
about why don't you wanna a lot of
[ __ ] yeah
oh here's something I do I do I got a
button that does that okay pretty cool I
saw you on the green room when you sat
with all those comedians whatever and
you were the young guy and they were all
like look at this young guy whatever but
there was one detail about that you
don't talk about it that's fine Ansel
well anyway I don't I'm I love Garry
Shandling
he's like I have nobody bad news for you
yeah wait what is it
he's fine though is he's living happily
he did yeah
yes rest in peace he would've liked that
maybe I dunno he's passed sadly but I
love so much this moment there and they
introduced you and you're like hey I'm
from the new generation and I and I was
just wondering who are you guys hmm and
I could tell a lot of them were rubbed
the wrong way by that a lot of the guys
were like I specifically I thought like
Marc Maron was like look at this [ __ ]
kid you know yeah but whatever well but
then Garry Shandling came out with this
beautiful response of like well that's
so great that you say that because the
feeling so mutual yeah I was perfect but
not only was he perfectly funny I feel
like you you were endeared to him and
that throughout the rest of it he was
very supportive and very accepting of
you and just really
sweetheart yeah and I was I'm just
wondering if you had any other
interactions what I did yeah I sort of
had a relationship with him going
forward like that's we like over yeah
you play ball with him I didn't it was
more just one-on-one just going over
there on weekends and like sitting with
him for a while and he actually read the
script of this movies one of the first
really hate it yeah Wow he's just super
nice and super deep and kind and just a
smart just a deep kind person which is
just very cool and very like patient and
open but yeah there's nothing worse than
five comedians sitting around performing
a violation I mean it's so [ __ ] nose
Hey I don't know that not that I like I
just mean like everyone trying to outdo
each other it's so no yeah I I feel like
that situation was something that I
would hate to ever be involved in just
because it's like it's so competitive it
has to be otherwise you just if you
don't want to compete to like prove how
funny or witty you are you just sit
there like a [ __ ] idiot yeah doing
bits in life is it gets very very
exhausting but that was a that was
actually kind of a fun one because I was
so young it was just like so different
and it felt like we could all just sort
of [ __ ] with each other a little bit but
yeah yeah Gary's a good dude I love him
I mean well okay I don't okay cool we
talked about that yeah great he's a very
zen Eastern now he's such a Buddhist guy
and like are you into that [ __ ] I wish I
was you feel like you could be and I
wish I was yeah I keep trying but then I
never do like I bought a bunch of books
and I'm like I'll read those someday
yeah but as they say it's in the buying
that the as they say yeah you just like
put the verb first but the books in your
shelf and they will by proximity man
who's stands less on toilet get high on
pot yeah right that was much better than
what I said what was yours it really
didn't go anywhere at all I don't know I
was a great thing I heard yeah any how
are you are you are you Buddhist are you
into all that they Eastern stuff I'm
more into the idea of religion than I
was as a cool-ass 19 year old atheist
you have come around not a round I just
like I don't really hold like it takes
up so little of my mind criticizing it
or no you you like felt you felt
probably we're younger than need to be
like I mean so he is God dude and now
I'm like I mean whatever you you get
through that right woman I feel the same
exact way there's something about when
you're young and you're like I'm [ __ ]
so smart I get this [ __ ] yeah you idiot
it's like you think there's a guy in the
sky ya know like there are people that a
lot smarter than you that are religious
so it isn't inherently Adama also it's
like what do you understand about the
universe you little [ __ ] idiot what
do you understand about your own head I
mean like like that's the thing is that
like the subjective experience is so
mind-blowing Lee impossible to
understand that sure god I mean I'm not
like I don't that we are any of any of
this is how is God weirder than like
anything that just existing I don't
believe in God necessarily but I don't
not believe in God yeah I I believe in
buying books about Buddhism putting on
my bookshelf yeah well we we pray to the
god of brick and mortar yeah um do you
go to a brick and mortar was it online
online come online I'm a home Smith you
think I'd show up around a bookstore
have you once awesome go to a bookstore
I'm gonna bookstores I like to walk
around a bookstore nice mom-and-pop shop
like an Amazon books you know the Amazon
makes bookstores those are great real
down-to-earth are you serious yeah that
bookstore yeah yeah they went and like
just like did you not have enough of the
market but they literally truck they
literally destroyed bookstores and then
like then and they're basically dancing
on the grid oh absolutely
no no they're like they're like [ __ ]
their wives on their graves yeah sorta
like Jeff's book store it's like this
dusty old [ __ ] place yeah yeah Amazon
bookstore I'll go to churches too when
I'm in the city I'll go to a church and
sit down you'll sit down through the
thing usually like on off hours cuz it's
like why do you go there do you pray
I'll see you on the plank yeah you find
that the environment yeah does something
quiet well sure I've been to churches
and cathedrals and there's definitely a
vibe yeah it's great it's like and like
you really can't be on your
when you're in there it's not even about
God it's almost just about like the
quietness of like just being there's
something divine in existence let's just
agree we don't agree on but let's just
say I think that but like you really
feel that there and it's like you don't
believe in Jesus Christ you don't have
to look at a guy in a cross but there's
something divine about being alive and
you feel that there and like silence is
as valuable as it's ever been
like silent attention is like so rare to
get a less stimulation can I go to a
church I'm Jewish by coarse ethnicity
yeah if you don't mind you're not gonna
pick me out they can be local some dudes
not gonna be like you look a little
Jewish can I see your ID he wouldn't say
a little straight ball he wouldn't come
out that's yeah thank you by the way if
you're cool with you know I think you're
you might I could go to a synagogue hell
yeah
where I belong yeah it's party there but
yeah churches for everybody I didn't
know that I think so is that what they
say no but no no I want a lot of them I
like my mom goes to like a Presbyterian
whatever in the the guy was like
anyone's welcome at this table if you're
trans if you're this if it was like
things are changing things are changing
can I talk about your mom your mom has a
really interesting vocation mm-hmm she
hospice Mercia she Mende Hospice at my
stupid boss mansion which is basically
she takes care of end of life yeah and
she works in a hospice center so a lot
of hospice nurses are out of you know
they'll go to they'll go to a dying
patient in their house but this is where
dying patients come and it's end-of-life
care so the average stay is two weeks no
one recovers you know when you go there
you do not leave she sees three or four
deaths a day what is it I'm curious just
systematically how people end up there
is it like a health insurance thing is
it like a government thing um that's a
great question
I mean it's it's it's when the dying
process starts
I mean it's when the illness is fully
move Ollie terminal you're moving out of
the hospital and into into a place where
it's called
end-of-life care where you're just
trying
I'm only curious about how that came in
to exhibit alike who runs that I have no
idea I don't this bit she's kind of like
where did that come from you know yeah
huh because the the most hospice is the
specific out of Institute like it's
actually just nurses going to take care
of you at home so you're dying in your
home this sort of thing a hospice center
is much much rarer but no it's a lot of
donations and things I mean like it's
not something you know like a for-profit
place but yeah it's pretty so how is
that like me and affected her and maybe
even you by Moxie I mean surely that
trickles down to your toes well yeah
he's just doing it 9 or 10 years now and
it's insane you know she after the first
two weeks of working there she forgot
the president's name so she went to the
hospital to get a cat scan because she
thought she'd a brain tumor and she went
to work the next day and her boss said
that just happens here you just forget
you know you're just gonna be blocking
so much of what's happening out here
that it's kamek that he's like oh if you
only told me I would have told you that
that happens to everybody here yeah yeah
exactly and like when she was getting
ready to interview for the place she saw
like a body getting carried out saying I
can't [ __ ] do this and then two weeks
in she's carrying a body out chatting
with the nurse's assistant you know puts
in the car and turns around it's like
whoa great and I'll be with her like a
diner and a family will come up and be
like patty patty oh my god like you know
cuz she saw her you know their you know
father through his last two weeks of his
life and they'll leave and she'll go I
don't remember them you know she's like
the most and she'll be some like the
most important people in some people's
lives for you know five of them a day
yeah and it's like I mean how does that
affect their personality changes I was
incredibly stable and like it's all
women you know it's like mostly all
women there and it's like oh it's like a
really incredible example of like the
sort of condescended stereotyped quality
of of women of like oh yeah women or
maternal and women are very caring but
it's like a a like military like as as
tough Oh
version of that is can be and you
actually realize that like caring is
actually is actually the most tough and
resilient thing you can actually do at
its extreme mmm that I'm saying people
come back from war you know unable to
[ __ ] process mm-hmm thoughts my
mother comes back from watching like a
40 40 year-old bleed out in front of his
family and she comes you know to like
you know smiles and cooks us dinner you
know like that is that is actual
strength you know and it is um yeah
she's wild wild stories wild that was
you know people dying of alcoholism and
she will dip a q-tip in Jack Daniels and
swab it in their mouth Wow
you know cuz it's just it's just people
dying of lung cancer she takes them out
she wields them out into the snow and
holds a cigarette to their lips cuz
they're too weak you know cuz it's just
end-of-life care it's not about there's
any it's also very medical she's also
like a nurse practitioner I mean she
said she knows what she's yeah we've
worked in the ER she's done these things
so but um yeah that's wild you know
that's gotta be one of the craziest
[ __ ] jobs you can possibly family
members showing up like threatening to
[ __ ] kill people like get my dad out
of here you shouldn't gonna mean like
I'm not adding to terms with that or
like there don't want them here they're
confused or they're you know it's well I
can say just from person like my wife
Ella is going through something with
their dad right now and like just
hearing her talk about is like it's so
it's just so [ __ ] up like we're so bad
at dealing with death we don't think
about it until it's there and so like
these women these nurses that are that
are like such rocks for people because
my mother will sit there and go like she
knows how to deal with it and she knows
what it looks like like I'm lying
everybody she knows how to deal with it
and it's in dealing with it isn't like
to make it easier but she she she she
can say like she's never seen last words
in her life ever
she says they almost they almost never
speak for the last two hours
mmm there is a last breath but there's
almost never a last word mmm it's like
really really incredibly incredibly fast
she's right but she was on an episode
of because I talked a little bit about
this on meirin's podcast like a long
time ago and Nancy Updike from this
American Life heard and they did this
American life and on my mom and you can
hear her in the hospice center it's it's
like in some people you know it sucks
for her because it's such an interesting
job and and of course it is emotionally
taxing and she needs to talk about it
but something like it's such a hard
thing to talk about because people hear
about and they go like I just can't
[ __ ] hear that but it definitely puts
it puts my job into perspective it very
easily yeah I mean where I can just be
like I don't give a [ __ ] what happens
with you know this thing or that like I
just I wonder if like we as a society in
this kind of [ __ ] ridiculous question
out there but like if we just dealt with
death better you know what I mean like
it's just it's this buggy we all
obviously know we're gonna die but like
the thought of it the prepping of it the
association of it the way that like we
prolong it even when it's over like this
this is what this is all is that when
people are dying and they're on death's
bed certain to die and they're suffering
there's no quality of life 11 the family
suffering the person suffering it's like
you put you prolong that for as long as
possible I don't understand that
yeah I think we've done better with
grief then we have death like there's
cult there's more of an infrastructure
for the grieving process you know I
think like we're more familiar with that
I'm saying before we may it like we've
experienced funerals we know what that
is we know that space a little bit those
are very public and yeah but the dying
process for people unfamiliar with it is
intense and my grand my father's father
died at the hospice center my mom was
working at but she couldn't work with
him because they don't let you work
conflict of interest yeah yeah well
there's interest but like yeah just like
[ __ ] up it's like it just wouldn't be
healthy or something yeah I mean but
yeah like my mother will come home like
having a rough day and say what was it's
like yeah I was a young person you know
it's like [ __ ] ins and it's in
Massachusetts in like this beautiful
weird Center all these windows and like
the seasons are changing and it's like I
would love to make a movie about it it's
just like a little crazy and heavy the
subject matters is very interesting and
I think it's something that
they should be explored honestly it's
like I wonder if there's a way to make
it that isn't brutally depressing you
know what I mean I know I don't think
there is but it could be beautifully
depressing maybe but like there's one
story that she told me that's like
incredible um one of her nurses aides um
a lot of immigrants that would that work
there and she was she was a Haitian
immigrant and she was in the room
holding something in her arms in a towel
and my mother was working with a older
gentleman who was very sick and sort of
out of it and my mother was like so
she's gonna take care of you now and the
old guy said some racial slur you know
this is a black woman who says like I
don't want that
whatever touching me or getting near me
mm-hmm my mother turns to the nurse and
she's like you know putting this stuff
in him that like conk sit on it for a
little bit so they can like change his
bedding and everything and my mom turns
to nurses aide and like you don't have
to do this like he said that's really
inappropriate you know I'll do this
don't worry and she's going no no no no
holding a thing going no no it's okay
it's okay okay like hearing all this and
my mother watches is the guy like dozes
off for a bit and the woman opens the
towel and she'd been warming lotion
while he's saying all this stuff to her
she was warming lotion for him he's
passed out sports that he gives him like
like works into his feet in his hands
that's after hearing your lazy
compassion I it's like incredible it's
like you know these the people that do
this or like true
truly angels and they're angels be and
then you I go to you know I go to the
hospital all the time to check in on you
know see my mom and it's like a bunch of
you know little Boston ladies being like
oh you're out in Hollywood oh my god I
mean they're like little it's incredible
it's it's so it's a crazy little world
there there was there was I think it was
an HBO show about it I never saw it but
they're moving I would definitely love
to watch anything about that it's just I
think it's documentary I'd be the best I
mean you the respect of the family makes
it like you cuz you can really do it but
I write that you should listen it's
called death and taxes that This
American Life I'll check it very
incredible
love it love that show well thanks for
sharing that yeah yeah um do you well
let's so let's switch gears yeah please
you know I used to do this thing at the
end of our show we used to ask people if
they had ghost stories but frankly I
don't I'd rather do something else with
you okay good yeah I don't yeah I didn't
think you would and I frankly don't
either I don't even know why it's still
going on it's like do you have ghost
stories are like knows like yeah I don't
either
um like our fans got into this thing
about ghost stories I'm like I don't I
don't believe in ghosts you guys
regardless I want to do a new thing oh
yeah which is that I have werewolf
stories do you have I find the perfect
video to watch with my guests oh yeah to
close up the show and I think I found
the perfect video to watch with you okay
okay so first of all let me hit you with
one of these
okay now bow and the house is an origin
meme it's kind of one of our earliest
and best memes and reactions are one of
the best videos on the Internet
it's Papa John yeah I actually do
remember this you know the Papa John's
do I do remember that there's the Torres
house right yeah yeah yeah yeah I
haven't seen this note so I thought we'd
watch it together
yeah I do have the name of some like
[ __ ] you mean like some [ __ ] kid
well there's no music well it'd be oh oh
he's be no you know this [ __ ]
spells his name you do you just said he
yeah yeah I was like that my French but
give me a [ __ ] break yeah yeah yeah
of course not I feel bad for him in a
way though he probably got his ass beat
in high school though
oh well the good thing well it's not
like we're bringing him up any again to
be shamed publicly in front of thousands
Wow he's grown up he's come to terms
with the psi-man Jen his dad is kind of
taking the heat off his dad like he was
on a conference call yeah he dropped the
n-bomb Papa doesn't have the best track
record yeah yeah so
Hoppa John man I love Papa John he's
like he's got sort of high curls oh you
know that that hot luxurious boy you
know what I always say about Papa John
he looks like a hammerhead shark he's
nope that's not what I say but I like it
it looks like he's stood too close to a
pizza oven for too long cuz you know
what I mean like this pulp of Zappa Papa
John here let's give you guys the whole
lore overview before we before we dive
in headfirst here no I don't want Google
to know my [ __ ] location he always
looks a little wet that is what I mean
like that the cheese is melted on his
face yeah he looks like that pizzas a
little overcooked you know what I'm
saying
all right yeah he looks like just it's
not he looks like his own wax sculpture
that's a good way to put it
he's clearly had some work but man
nothing can fix man that left eye is
nothing trying to look at something else
nothing could have fixed look at those
brows bro a couple pepperonis look at
that like this Danny Zuko curl he's
trying to rock up top and like I mean
that like I will say to his credit he's
an incredible bit he said he really was
a guy with the pizza joint that grew it
out of nowhere yeah well you know what
some pizza joints got to work so yeah I
mean here let me show you this I mean
wait is Papa John's the one with the
garlic sauce yeah it's actually pretty I
love Papa John's yeah it started from a
real place this whole Papa bless it
started from a real place of love for
Papa you know I mean he'll various
shit-faced uh-huh I mean here you go get
it close up yeah he's got a real 90s
magician vibe right yeah like Abe
remember that shows on ABC with a guy
would wear white mask and expose all
that I love that every magician would at
home would be like what the [ __ ] dude
that was him the one angry but was it I
wanted to show you oh I don't know if
there's so much Papa John content to
show you Papa is in the house is really
this is nuts not this is like a separate
computer just for this right
I would like never broadcast my web
browser I lived like be terrifying
so know that well yeah yeah yeah yes yes
you see my related video you'd be like
no
okay no no no this is just for here baby
I'm all good no history on this one yeah
it's like Destiny's Child feet that was
giving no I feel you man
here this is the one I want to show you
just the beginning they staged this
whole ridiculous promotional thing I
love how he thinks he's like a celebrity
like he's a pizza celebrity you know
what I mean he's a it's a [ __ ] oh hey
you know what though he spoke it into
existence man yeah he wanted to be
coming to became it he did well not me
not what he wanted but he did become
something been the higher they climbed
the harder they fall
very true so anyway they went and set
this whole thing up like he's supposed
to go to this culinary school and
teaching people how to make a pizza but
it's so obviously fake I mean but he has
people I mean just enjoy this yeah there
everyone's got paper plates and the host
is just the most flattering [ __ ]
judge a bear I just got this it's it
cannot be over you that's incredible
alright I get to the [ __ ] point I
like this yeah I like this part in the
show where we're like already hour and a
half in so now it's like nobody's really
watching Yeah right right so it's like
the pressure is really off at this point
this guy's the CEO of secrets of
Louisville chefs so apparently it's part
as a series right here look at is this
not like I just like a fever dream
it feels like Tim and Eric yeah exactly
yeah the mural is an insane at the back
hold on you
he's got a laugh and they don't mute it
so you can hear him making these really
weird sounds like he goes like like that
oh my god was you know credible I
somehow I've never made a video about
this because there's ray there's only a
few wonderful moments like this but the
rest is just so boring no no no but this
is beautiful and like 93,000 is truly
under the radar oh yeah oh yeah I'm sure
they put a lot of marketing in this but
here oh I didn't go back one can we stop
for that I mean he is like it's it's
listen he's Pappajohn sometimes that's
enough it wasn't enough when was this
yesterday all the [ __ ] went down right
yeah
it's weird little [ __ ] he's probably
doesn't as the but he does not have the
best track record he he was when it was
in the news first when he was like I'm
not gonna [ __ ] increase my pizza
prices by one cent to give my employees
health care because of Obamacare they
were like you cheap [ __ ] probably
John I mean if if if the CEOs of our
pain our celebrity CEOs of our pizza
chain restaurants can't survive the
current cultural moment who can yeah I
feel like I'm next and you know what the
thing is it's like we don't have to get
into a [ __ ] ham or whatever but like
we have to take him so seriously because
it's like it's kind of like he could be
President so we just literally we have
to take him seriously yeah we actually
have to be worried about this that like
if that's the problem with the culture
and I want to get in all that [ __ ] you I
mean but like what's insane is that like
if the entire culture exists on the same
level and on the same plane and it
mimics our [ __ ] phone
it's like you scroll through your
Twitter and you or your Instagram and
you will see in no particular order your
mother your friend
Geico the president the United States
Kim Kardashian and it's like and that's
what the national conversation has
become like it's just all the same it's
like when Kanye freaked out we have to
take them seriously cuz like what's the
[ __ ] difference there is only one
conversation being you join I'm saying
yeah it's like well we're yeah it kind
of like we I would just be the guy [ __ ]
this guy but it's like no like we have
to actually keep an eye on our pizza
guys because they may run the [ __ ]
world yeah it's crazy yeah no I think
that's true well and similarly he got in
trouble when he said that the NFL people
need to stop protesting because it's
affecting pizza prices did you see that
whole thing when the kneeling NFL player
or yeah NFL and he was like listen I'm
gonna pull my sponsors he was like their
number one sponsor and if these guys
keep yelling because our pizza sales are
down since they started protesting
that's crazy but and the nailing things
like I personally and publicly have I've
always been like what is why do you
[ __ ] care but also like don't we know
that like the Department of Defense pays
like 50 million dollars like that all
the flag [ __ ] is advertisements for the
military the department defense pays the
NFL like well why pay them to do a
salute yeah all the other reuniting
troops and stuff those are paid paid
stage things - that's [ __ ] so like no
wonder they're angry obviously because
like you're it's not that like you're
kneeling during the anthem it's like no
no you're kneeling during our ad time
judging our art no this is answer yeah
yeah no this is a we paid for this [ __ ]
to be an advertisement and your that's a
[ __ ] great advertisement that is
exactly people that are go sign up hmm
yeah and then like and like chill
whatever I mean I think it should be
stated you mean like I'm saying it's not
I don't think whatever doesn't the FCC
have rules like I as a youtuber need to
disclose when I'm sponsored the military
sponsors the NFL nobody needs to be like
hey this is a page this national anthem
is a paid sponsorship yeah it's that's
[ __ ] creepy crazy yeah well yeah I
mean oh well let's get them off the
field in that case I don't know they're
disparaging the sponsor yeah exactly now
do we got a brother
yeah yeah well anyway can we please
acknowledge them mm-hmm it's too good no
but that is truly that is what I search
for it's like the micro moments of those
this is a beautiful micro moment yeah
yeah and boom goes the dynamite is so
good because it it's like it's one after
a [ __ ] point that very well yeah I
mean goes the dynamite that he coined
that I don't know it's his now I mean if
he coined that then but that's what's so
sad about is he's flailing and then in
the but he's back to the thing that he
wanted to say if it went well which goes
the dynamite but yeah it's like so what
do you feel for pop right now do you
sympathize with them no okay no like
sympathize with this man it's hilarious
you want I just can't believe like I
just can't believe what the headlines
look like yeah like Papa John it's crazy
drop raise Muppet John dropped the N
bomb on conference call with Board of
Directors yeah and you're like yeah and
that should be funny or weird or like
I'm saying it should be like some weird
face off and not look indistinguishable
from like geopolitical headlines
I totally hear you I think I have this
problem with Twitter News which I love
Twitter news it's almost like it's like
a [ __ ] IV of all this [ __ ] right
into my vein like I don't almost use
Twitter at all just the news yeah times
yeah album is like what happened with
Shane Dawson somebody just out of the
blue what was it then they accused him
of being a pedophile or some [ __ ] what
was it but it was just like so unfounded
and they ran it as this headline and I
was like damn that shouldn't be you know
like you said next to to the point where
he said he was getting like accosted at
Starbucks and stuff right like just
because some [ __ ] blasted on there
that's not it let's let's not let's not
veer off too far but no but it's
incredible to talk about the dangers of
the Internet while also showcasing them
bite during its thing
yeah I mean this thing is so [ __ ]
awesome look at this it's got pictures
yeah I'm very excited about that like
and you can customize it I've got
another one I mean we I mean this is
just the beginning like yeah I'm gonna
have a lot of fun right as I get I get
this what you want to do it I've got a
little bit go enjoy so let's let's
venture forth bravely if if we may oh
we're doing this still yeah okay this is
why I brought you here clearly okay but
the pizzas [ __ ] good like you could
say oh oh
Wagner was a Nazi you could Bob there
was a Nazi you know what like his music
was pretty dank dank
is the word I think he was hoping people
would think it was dank yeah I mean it's
you know the chick-fil-a thing it's like
those sandwiches pretty hairy [ __ ]
dank well that's the conversation can we
separate the art from the pizza mogul
can we separate the the garlic sauce
yeah probably
what looks like waterlogged young
vampire ready yeah that's a good
description like that some-some rumored
that the garlic sauce is the secret of
his loss of his long life is that right
yeah it's like a slight more it's
probably quite the opposite for everyone
else you think he's he doesn't drink
that garlic sauce I drink it you do
[ __ ] I throw the pizza I drink that
[ __ ] really no you don't right you're in
school I used to need them that in
school we used to think you're like
fifth grade we would line up shots of
russian dressing
dude right did you like the dressing or
was it meant to be gross it was like at
that age when it's like there's no
you're not doing drugs and stuff so
you're like getting a - Cassie yeah
you mean like sweet all right there was
one friend we used to pay to eat
anything weird like he was up for
anything that reminds me of any [ __ ]
thing I'm telling you bro hair really
dog [ __ ] okay one dollar
way anything wait he ate a dollar or for
one dollar or one dough okay I'll give
you a dollar I thought you were trying
to get worse going to do you need
anything hair [ __ ] a dollar well to be
frank that may be the grossest one yeah
who dollars yeah we said friends these
do poo dollar OSA you put poo on a
dollar and you leave it outside like oh
yes and then everyone's like a dollar
yeah and then there's [ __ ] on it but
it's it was law jackass that was a big
part of my childhood I met Steve oh
sweet guy oh he was on here oh I was
like he's really cool okay yeah
yeah they were important I agree as
important as Papa that was another one
that was a different one it's so loud
alright don't act like I didn't pay
everyone to be here you [ __ ] I'm very
proud to be here and this advertisement
I paid for and the racism in hindsight
is pretty is there he's a good old boy
yeah in all the ways that a good old boy
is a good what it's also just like the
mural then I don't know where the mural
is killing me these giant onions yeah
the harvest the bounty was sweet this
year Papa just like this sharp who do
you think out who do you think picked
those let me just put it that way on
Papa's a plantation mm-hmm Pass look at
this 309 153 all right bye anyway this
this isn't why we're here are you I'm
out of water
Ian can I can I get a glass a little
reader well can we get a refill for
Christ's sake thank you
so this is really the the croup de Gras
is that is that right
croup DeGraw qu can this be a coup de
Gras this video no I don't think so I
saw it just looks confused I don't know
that is what is coup de Gras it's like
the crack it's like the final blow yeah
the final blow
they um I'm waiting for it
he's the worst it's all good yeah good
guy in the intern now he's the worst you
don't know don't say that you don't know
I'm like I don't you just being nice
don't do it thanks see and you're the
best appreciate you and you got the
bottoms of that tracksuit oh who said it
is that good or bad I don't know no I'm
telling you but he's not wearing them
you don't like the whole Adidas
tracksuit look note on him I'm on board
now dude [ __ ] that guy alright so this
is in its entirety this beautiful
wonderful advertisement that Papa John
made with the Sun is fave helper and his
best friend Bo
to celebrate their Papa John calm come
in life 2010 and this is the title they
used this isn't someone else they put
this here Papa and son first order on
the new Papa John calm ok ok ok now the
first thing I already love about this is
like I'm so relatable and behind me is a
mausoleum yeah it's like a [ __ ] huge
statue of an eagle yeah yeah that's
crazy I love it also it's a wedding ring
is that thing is its glyphic a lot of
yeah yeah a lot of pizza has been sold
them by that also he's just cruising
around this Papa John sure like this is
how I hang out at home yes crazy the lot
the untuck long-sleeve red the
long-sleeve Collard Papa John's shirt I
love that they have him just wearing
that every day at home it projects
business yet casual rolled-up sleeves
worker um you know I was just you know
digging one of my maid's graves oh hey
there yeah oh you caught me
I was just digging a grave for one of my
fallen maids the secret ingredient
that's a good one
broke did you really have to do the set
your [ __ ] here's the church here's the
steeple open the doors
no Jews no Jews that's the Papa John
that's Papa John what was that was that
one of the old school playground thing
oh of course you don't know this here's
the church here's the steeple open the
doors look at all the people no no it's
not how they used to say that back in
2010 people say that about Jews mmm
didn't know that he'll know Jews I feel
like he should have done this somewhere
else is all like you have a [ __ ]
dragon in your Hall and like made of
gold in your hallway like wait what is
that well it looks like uh it's
something let's go looks like a Gyarados
it's hard to tell man
is that a mythical creature oh it's what
magic harp revolves in - oh yeah that's
a mythical creature don't say no it's
not a myth pokemon myth it's a only I
wish so much the Pokemon was real when I
was a kid oh my god oh thanks man was
where it was at I didn't play snap that
was the best why what what's not the
picture one right uh woman you take
pictures I don't it was like perfect it
was crazy for n64 I'm waiting for a
Pokemon on the switch man I can't
[ __ ] wait for a 3d Pokemon Oh
Biddy yeah well you know like oh yeah
like uh you know what I'm talking to
totally yeah I'm saying so relatable man
so glad you did in your [ __ ] house
like why did you do this in your house
do it at a pizza store he's almost like
he's flexing on us yeah it's a lot hey
this is to grow up I have feel those
clocks I have over this kid he's like
yeah well you can see that the deadness
in his eyes I mean here
yeah for Bo he's doesn't gotten over
this was the house oh that's so sad yeah
no it is that Oh his body to the the
baggy shirts not hiding it Bo in the
house post the weakest hands in the air
yeah it's like damn how old it's a
weight that kids what all day he's
probably 12 or so he's 20 now yeah bo if
you're out there dude I love you we
forgive you your dad made bomb ass
pizzas but you do not have to be what he
is I mean I hope you make pizzas I hope
you carry on that family legacy because
that is a valuable I like the pizzas
yeah maybe you should start Bo's pizza
yeah Papa Bo yeah shet himself the hole
you're gonna have to change the spelling
though because people won't relate to
that yeah you don't have to live in the
shadow of your father you can do your
own that's a thing yeah not anything
just you can do I was afraid you're
gonna say you can do any no no you can
do anything in the pizza industry this
is like Foxcatcher eating Foxcatcher
this is like what I wish Foxcatcher well
I mean foscar's weren't my favorite
movies ever what is it what is it but
John du Pont who like this is a crazy
millionaire billionaire who like had a
bunch of like wrestlers come wrestle on
is like mansion property men are you
know it it the movies with Steve Carell
and Channing Tatum and Mark Ruffalo it's
incredible it's so weird and amazing but
this for my time is that almost would
like to watch a reality show with these
two yeah almost
oh I feel I love you Maddie
what's this whole angle like it's like
they're like we need a family angle on
this I get to do with you you know after
this camera goes off he's like [ __ ] you
dad yeah of course I don't know you know
what though I don't know they love each
other I mean I think Bo's genuine I
think he's a real dude really in this
moment you think he's being real well
here let me play it shot him he's night
that night pizza he's got all the moves
I'm just waiting for the Thunder to
settle okay I might take a little pizza
I'm scared and wish he had a
relationship with mom still yeah yeah
I'm anxious all the time and I prefer
Little Caesars frankly call him
jalapenos and to be frank with you
I know it's jalapeno and ever since
Nielsen hello what yeah jalapeno that's
what you said right right
I know Tala Pino it's jalapeno jalapeno
I know that though I know that I know
what the double L means can I say that
double l jalapeno the double O makes a
why sound are we confused if there is
you else in jalapeno oh my god don't
think there are right okay the point is
let's let's go let's let's rewind this
it's not Michael P no it's like a pain
yet hold on let's rewind this anytime I
sound like an idiot I go I'm Dyslexic
but but the point I wanted to maybe
successful this ability you can be you
can be successful without learning to do
this just ask
mozart Einstein exactly he was a
Asperger he had Asperger's he wasn't an
ass I thought that's out was said no I
know that it's jalapeno jalapeno
jalapeno okay jalapeno I know it was
something like that
okay but once I watch it it's all you
didn't jalapeno am I getting am i okay
am i passing the test
see I think wow no please
ride that button to Valhalla but once I
watched this I started saying jalapeno
and I couldn't stop like yes and and
it's actually a problem I call it a
jalapeno no it's also like who you know
whatever yeah we can we can end it there
I'm saying we're mostly white yeah super
butchers you know maybe we're doing
croissant and we can leak have our way
but they're not have our way but like
when it went when like a when I went a
late lame white person like overreaches
- that's all wood that's that's also
like you know just normal
it's like all good no it's weird when
they go like when they go like I hate
that it's just like oh yeah what do you
think you are you're my dad doesn't yeah
time to when we go to Mexican restaurant
yeah he starts doing like jive with the
with the Mexican waiters like speaking
fucked-up Spanish them right I'm like
dude you how do you even know they speak
Spanish they're probably American but
maybe it's respect because I was just
thinking I don't know it can't yeah I'm
just saying it maybe it is I'm saying I
if like if I find it embarrassing I'm
saying something like Chinese guy came
over it was like hamburger I'd be like
okay thanks I mean I don't know so maybe
it's cool
wow thanks for being thoughtful hey I
just look like a hamburger there's a
very funny thing is actually in Sweden
they did a show where they're like
speaking and they're doing the
equivalent of like four Swedish we'd be
like oh like Walter Walter Walter we're
and they do it for English they're not
speaking English but what English
surprise to them and it's a bunch of
people going like
purdah nation karuppa taraj para
favorite - total Achara
i guess that's what it sounded like to
them it's all like our Batian - great
yeah that's a good one to look up but
so if you are a minority please hit them
with those hard arse next time you see
me yeah it'll be very respectful well I
can't I Johnny hit that hard ah yeah
yeah yeah he hit that are a little too
hard don't hit it that hard
don't ever hit no one but I can't I
can't really tell if it's respectful or
embarassing to like speak [ __ ] up
Spanish to somebody you know I think you
know it's said that maybe my dad yeah
your dad no because like I know people
that are fluent that like of course
nobody every thing he does embarrasses
me you know and I'm like a grown man and
he still is capable of embarrassing me
so brutally that I hold my head in shame
yeah that's part of the power daddy
wield it's beautiful though yeah that's
the job that's the job yeah okay well
regardless we are we we were flying
through this we really gotta push yeah
you [ __ ] idiot why would you even
admit that it's not endearing he thought
it was endearing yeah you know I've
never been on the internet before ever
ordered anything is that right it is
that what laptops look like eight years
ago
what's he like Cheers he's like Dell
that you like this is really a time
capsule of like eight years eight short
years look at what the chairs look like
back then hmm rich Mahara living in
castles back then Wow things were much
better where the mm-hmm bone-chilling
where are all those sounds that we know
he makes I wish we had those on there
[Music]
damn we're gonna the sound bite those
seem to really have entered some heat on
that couple sorry pops oh we need to
sound bites Odie pops so again I heard
I've watched this video and I can't stop
saying Saudi pops now yeah
Saudi pop sorry which is so good that's
cute
so good it's it is cute it's sweet thing
oh there was a little faux pas there
there was a little mess up there that I
haven't noticed before
oh never mind he's like okay yeah I
thought it was someone off screen being
like all right okay so okay good banter
there oh wait you were actually I was
like whoa I don't remember being there
there's really not much to say at this
point I feel like just a couple of old
good old boys ordering a pie oh here
this is great
this is nailed that one I love Matt love
Matt while look at Matt you know what
Matt is real Matt is real oh yeah
no Matt didn't even know they were
shooting Matt's you really tell it's
like it is real yeah that's why I love
Matt so much and here's this point where
Papa he needs to point out here so you
can see it gave you tip big Tim
nice boat you'd get it dude but like
crowd there's new dad I feel a kinship
with this kid
you like y'all's dad the business yeah I
mean he's got the sweet ass like you
know sort of straight yeah like he's got
this thing yeah on I feel good you are
low so here I want to wrap it up with
this beautiful last moment here Matt you
made history today goddamnit good job
Matt you're the greatest man surprise
you get to [ __ ] my wife in front of me
you think he let Matt in he's got that
vibe he's got a [ __ ] you think so
literally we can't even say cuckolding
anymore cuz now it's got political oh
that's true it's kind of lost all
meaning well that was it that's all I
have
bro I freeze a lot of fun yeah thanks
for being here
it was it was really an honor and
pleasure to to meet you and hang out
with you hey and don't be part of this
I've been alone a long time viewer first
time BR here that's insane that you
washed our stuff thank you and I want it
what are you doing good work and I
appreciate it and like thanks a lot of
other people do and the girl in the
movie is a huge fan of yours you seemed
so excited can I do to like show her
appreciation I don't know just she just
hearing this will be she's amazing I
love her Kelsie Fisher she's great if
you're in New York or LA I see the movie
and it'll be other places other other
times 99 percent on Rotten Tomatoes this
movie is a heartwarming it's wholesome
it's a [ __ ] or romp it's a beautiful
little slice of life it's it's gonna
you're gonna love it and you're gonna
leave thinking about it and the best way
possible can I say that you said it I
said it I didn't you permission
thank you either please go see eighth
grade it's gonna be out nationwide in
two weeks and thank you so much bo you
can see it in New York in LA but who
cares kind of hard thank you for having
me it's kind
hard to catch its insulae select
theaters yeah you know catched if you
can it'll be in the like ten more cities
next weekend and then everywhere the we
connect everywhere everywhere baby right
Thank You Bo oof
thank you guys for watching we love you
and appreciate you and we will most
definitely be seeing you next week
thanks everybody
Tata
[Music]